a lot of people in this town think well
I'll just wait till I get to a certain
level and I'll have my team right right
and we're seeing from you that you are
the team you you just you do it so where
did you learn this trait is it something
you model yourself after someone you
know well I tell you you know the truth
is is that I do have an amazing support
group like I don't think no one can do
something like this by themselves no
movies made by themselves I mean um but
like there are people like you know like
i said my DP my editor my producers you
know my talent everybody pulls together
but at the end of the day it's like yeah
if you have a problem you come to me and
we we talk about it and I I don't know I
people I admire you know I there
certainly artists out there that they
kind of do everything that have their
hands and everything and anytime you
look at somebody something like you know
Orson Welles great work or you know
Woody Allen or any of these people that
are everything you know to their the
motor pushing it through um I think
that's more than my job I'm the motor
you know and I start from beginning and
go all the way through but it wouldn't
be I would be useless without the other
parts and the people that you know help
me do this but people have really they
get on board when they believe in
something and so that's what's exciting
is a you know leading this thing that
has this whole group of people that are
kind of making it move that make sense
um but yeah I feel like you know us in
the independent film world it's like we
learned pretty quickly that you don't
get the hand off the movie once you pass
the finish line you know there is no
finish line I'm still dealing with you
know it lawsuits about my last movie
trying to get people paid what they
should have been paid ages ago you know
but you know bigger companies that just
take advantage of independent film I
mean that movie was three years ago and
I'm still I have phone calls three or
four times a day because nobody's going
to do it with me and I don't know that
that's a something I learned it's much
as something I had a horrible
realization of one day
that nobody was going to take over so
it's um you know it's a commitment for
life and that's you know basically
that's what I told you know the
investors for you know for weather girls
like this movie will be around as long
as technology exists there will be some
form of weather girl and hopefully it
will continue to pay back dividends not
only you know financially but also you
know you could show that movie that you
helped make you know 20 years later to
you know a grandkid or something again
I'm fully rambling off the subject now
but but it takes a village is basically
what I was a very well in terms of the
fact that there are things that behind
the scenes don't go well and they're
give you some things that are very
troublesome what keeps you going so that
you want to go on to the next project a
lot of people don't think about all the
baggage that comes with success and some
of the things that can go wrong so then
what sparks you so that you keep going
well I you know the goal for me is um I
used to have all these if expectations
this is what I want in life I want this
and this and this and now I've kind of
realized that I would be happy just
doing this like so from the first day
I'm writing the script for six month
rule I just want to get that made so
that I can get to make another book
thing and you know it's it's constant
like that because I mean that's what I
want to do that's what that's what I
like doing and my my thought process
flawed though it may be is that if I do
this right and I do this well then I
should get an opportunity to do it again
and it doesn't always work out that way
but that's what you hope you know and so
yeah giving up the or not focusing on
the next project is not really an option
because I know nobody's going to show up
with you know the dream project and say
congratulations here you go here's this
james bond movie you've always wanted to
direct neural oh thank you very much i
really appreciate that probably not the
way that it's going to come down what's
gonna come happen is hopefully the movie
does well and successful then i can go
back
I can do it with another movie another
project and you know just keep trudging
along and leave a a wake of good work
you know that's the goal when you came
here 15 years ago where it was um did
you think that you would be where you
are now no no that's I it's so funny how
um like if you had told me when I was 23
that I was going to be a director you
know and filmmaker and all that jazz I
just wouldn't believe you because when I
was 23 you couldn't make a movie for
less than you know a couple million
dollars you know I mean you probably
could but um you know was all filmed it
was all very expensive and very
intimidating to me and now i think i'm a
real i'm a product of the time in which
i live i think that it's fantastic that
you know I I could make a movie for
$80,000 was how much outside sales cost
that was my first movie and I was making
some money acting and a buddy of mine
was making money in business and we
throw our money together and bought a
house because we thought it this is
great investment and we decided to form
this production company and make a movie
and we sold our house to finance that
first movie so I mean that was amazing
you know and it like the fact that that
worked out the way that it did and prove
to me that I could direct a movie is the
only reason I'm standing here now and
yeah it's a it's not where I thought I'd
be but it's way better it's way better
like at that time I was just waiting to
get cast and stuff now I have a hand in
the work that I do and the actors
standing across from me which one of my
favorite things you know I really like
about acting in the movie that I'm
directing its that this team I built it
you know I me and my team have built it
but it's not just me showing up and
being like who am i acting opposite
today oh I hope they're cool i hope
they're nice like I get to take actors
that I think are awesome and give them
the opportunity to to show me and
getting to act and seams with them
really really is fun for me
you